l'heure est venue de vous parler de
cette jolie bête que j'ai dans la main
sale là le nouveau macbook pro 13 pouces
je vous ai déjà présenté deux jours j'ai
fait le boxing avec vous et ça fait
quelques jours maintenant que je les
utilise et que j'utilise tout le temps
quotidien
j'ai switché pro 15 pouces au macbook
pro 16 pouces ça s'est vraiment bien je
sais pas si vous êtes utilisateurs
d'apple mais il ya tout eu vraiment
génial chez apple qui est très simple
ces systèmes de transfert de pouvoir
faire d'un mac à l'autre vous prenez un
disque dur vous faites une time machine
vous êtes sauvegarder tout vous donnez
tous votre confie-t-elle qu'elle est là
dans la time machine ça vous fait une
copie numérique vous allez pouvoir tout
importer votre time machine vous prenez
vous brancher en gros vous faire mon
ordinateur vous ouvrez l'autre vous
retrouver exactement la même chose
toutes vos données telle qu'elle était
faite les mises à jour entre temps est
quand même plutôt bien et vous avez tous
sur une nouvelle machine qui est
extrêmement performante ans le toque et
pose un peu frustrant c'est que c'est
effectivement très transparent aux
condiments final j'ai la même machine
c'est la même chose sauf que non en
réalité quand vous ouvrez les programmes
arrière quand vous fait pédaler la
machine ça va beaucoup plus vite c'est
vraiment cool et on pousse les dessous
d'un écran 16 pouces d'un écran 15
pouces ça apporte plus de confort c'est
vraiment hypra gamme
ça fait plusieurs jours j'utilise et
voilà enfin maintenant venu le moment où
vous dé brive toulouse exactement ce que
j'entends
[Musique]
non
ça fait déjà un bon moment que je suis
équipé apple et que j'utilise un macbook
pro pour pouvoir travailler le sujet
après à faire tous mes montages soit
final cut
je travaille que sur final cut ce qui
est bien mais ce qui est aussi peut être
un inconvénient parce que je ne
travaille pas sous première je ne
connais pas premiers donc je ne suis pas
flexible pour passer d'un mac un pc si
je le souhaite
donc je suis mac mac mac pour tout ce
qui est vidéo tout ce qui est montage ça
ça me va c'est la façon de bosser pour
moi c'est vraiment cool
j'aime bien familial que ça très
intuitif facile à faire facile à
travailler facile à monter
et plus le temps passe plus je connais
de choses plus efficace plus je peux
aller vite mais ça c'est cool et je
trouve ça vraiment intéressant de voir
bosser avec final cut sur cette machine
là parce que d'une l'écran est un peu
plus grand et croyez moi le fait d'avoir
un gap entre le 15 pouces et le 16
pouces
c'est pas énorme quand on le regarde
comme ça on ne dit pas waouh c'est
vachement plus grand mais c'est quand
même plus de confort et ça c'est quand
même vraiment agréable alors là je vous
parle de file d'al qods vous parle de
montage pour ce pack vous vous serez
forcément un montois vous ne faites pas
forcément des vidéos mais il ya plein
d'autres cadeaux qui sont très
intéressants le jour il ya eu un
briefing chez apple nous en montre
effectivement les nouveaux produits avec
toute une équipe de cuppertino qui
étaient là qui disait ok je vous montre
vous explique qu'on peut faire avec et
il ya plein de choses dit printemps
on en reparlera ce que je détestais le
gâteau est quand même pas trop si vous
faites de la vidéo si vous faites de la
musique avec logic vous pouvez utiliser
votre mac vous mettez votre ipad pro qui
synchronisées vous utilisez votre ipad 3
côté pouvoir régler à des plugins
cotiser pour gérer la thaïlande et tout
ça avec votre stylet donc ça c'est
vraiment intéressant ça non beaucoup
disaient qu'ils sont vraiment vraiment
cool et quand vous avez une machine
comme ça qui est extrêmement performante
alors ça dépend de la config que vous
avez si vous prenez tout ce qu'ils
valent mieux
et bien croyez moi c'est un vrai plaisir
il n'y a pas de ralentissement ça marche
bien on rentrera plus dans le détail
j'aime tout expliqué je veux donner
vraiment mon retour d'expérience par
rapport à cette bécane là et franchement
je suis très satisfait il ya une vraie
différence entre la config que j'ai sur
le macbook pro 15 pouces et la confie
que j'ai ici sur le macbook pro 13
pouces
on garde le même design en fait c'est
qu'on regarde comme ça c'est exactement
le même design on arrive à shiki fait à
peine 2 kg avec de prime abord quand
vous regardez comme ça on a le même
design que sur le macbook pro 15 pouces
on a les mêmes codes l'écran par contre
est un peu plus grand au niveau du
clavier c'est pareil on a le même
fonctionnement un énorme trackpad la
vote labiale clavier différence je vous
montrais dans quelques instants il ya
des nouveautés notamment le retour de la
touche et skype qui est là on va le
détail dans quelques instants mais d'un
point de vue
en général c'est la même chose on est
sur un macbook pro apple gamme le design
qui fait sa force
on voit la patte on reconnaît la marque
ça marche plutôt bien même derrière ici
là c'est exactement le même profil
exactement le même design des macbook
pro on ne change pas une équipe qui
gagne
le truc qui va être un petit peu
différent c'est les bords sur le côté je
veux déjà montré leur donne boxing vous
avez des bordes qui ont été réduits sur
le côté mais également sur le haut ça
vous permet d'avoir un macbook pro plus
fin avec un écran qui occupait plus d
espace c'est beau c'est joli c'est
efficace ça ça marche l'écran parlons-en
justement on a un écran retina 16 pouces
3072 pixels pas 1920 pixels
une fois de plus les dalles sont
maîtrisées par apple c'est une dalle ip
est ce que je trouve lumineuse
moi je voulais pas pousser à fond dans
les soupes ou stack la luminosité à fond
je trouve lumineuse de bonne qualité la
calibration est vraiment bien que ça
pour travailler académie de contenus
multimédia pour naviguer sur internet
sur tout ce que vous voulez on a
vraiment une machine extrêmement
performante qui reste dans l'adn de ce
que sait faire apple c'est à dire des
machines extrêmement bien calibré très
efficace très élégante et ça ça marche
à noter que l'expérience audio est
intéressante vous avez bien évidemment
du son stéréo mais vous avez un son qui
est hyper bien spatialisé parce que vous
avez pas moins de six haut parleurs tout
autour de la bécane ça vous permet de
profiter d'un son plus diversifiés sont
claires un son de bonne qualité
compatible dolby et moss et lorsque vous
les faire à des conférences discuter
échanger faveur facetime tout ce que
vous voulez vous avez pas moins de trois
micros qui vont être là pour optimiser
la captation de votre voix réduire le
bruit ambiant
donc ça aussi c'est vachement bien on va
se faire un petit test journée de la
musique alors le micro et sur moi j'ai
un micro cravate qui est posée sur moi
donc là vous êtes vraiment à l'appel
d'utilisateurs on reste longtemps que la
musique regarder tac tac tac sur arte
liste je vous montre où vous allez voir
le son est vraiment il prat cool
voici vous rendez compte mais là il ya
quand même vachement sont alors là je
les pousser à fond il voyait dans la
tête du bar je peux vient ensuite le
module et comme je veux mais il ya un
son qui est vraiment clair qui est bonne
qualité ça c'est vraiment ultra cool et
en plus un sou qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est un travail qui était
par apple pour réduire les vibrations
lorsque vous avez la main sur la machine
vous écoutez de la musique comme la à
fond eh bien vous ne sentez pas de
vibration particulière que poser
maintenant n'importe où eh bien il ya
une bonne répartition
je ne sens pas un ordinateur qui va
vibrer avec le son et ça croyez moi
c'est vraiment cool parce que vouloir
écouter de la musique fort continue à
travailler comme ça un trackpad ou taper
et pas se retrouver avec une main qui
bouge au rythme de la musique le son est
clair le son de bonne qualité d'une
expérience immersive et là dessus aussi
les vrais belle maîtrise de la part
d'apple
on laisse beaucoup obligés de parler un
peu très fort avec toute cette musique
très forte mais c'est vraiment cool
parce que quand on a alors dit comme ça
quand on travaille d'uzès pro par
exemple comme moi macbook pro usage
professionnel forfait du montage eh bien
on veut pouvoir avoir une qualité qui
vraiment beau d'un son qui est très
juste pour pouvoir vraiment permettre de
retranscrire au mieux ce qu'on fait et
ça c'est cool alors quand on parle aux
jo on m'a aussi parlé de la prise jack
enfin tant du côté de la connectique là
là vous avez regardé un peu je me
planque
là vous avez une petite prise jack jack
3.5 qui vous savez vous branchez votre
caste lorsque vous voulez par mettez
tout le monde voulait vous isolez vous
êtes un casque série travail
professionnel tout ce que vous voulez de
passer complètement possible et vous
allez aussi quatre ports thunderbolt roi
vous en avez deux ce côté là tandis
qu'ici vous avez les deux autres c'est
pour sedan contre amos arrière pour
brancher par exemple des disques durs
externes si vous voulez bosser dessus
notamment pour la vidéo c'est pas quand
vous prenez un stockage en 512 et vous
voulez pouvoir travailler qu'un disque
dur externe et bien vous pouvez vous les
brochures thunderball 3 c'est bon ça
écrit vite c'est très très cool
possédant jusqu'à deux moniteurs sica et
qui dit macbook pro dit surtout
performances des machines performantes
une machine qui a pouvoir tout faire
calculer très rapidement faire vos rendu
le plus rapidement possible ça c'est
vraiment tout l'adn de cette décade
alors vous avez choix entre deux config
intel core i7 intel core i9 la carte
graphique c'est une amd radeon pro
series 5000m vous valez jusqu'à 64 giga
de mémoire et 8 ra au niveau de votre
stockage en ssd
alors moi ma bécane j'ai une config qui
est vraiment il praille prat cool j'ai
un intel core i9 qui cadencé à 2.4
gigahertz 32
il ya de mémoire ddr4 deux terrains de
stockage en ssd et j'ai une amd radeon
pro 5500m 8 giga de mémoire gddr5
j'ai donc une machine qui est vraiment
cool qui est hyper optimisé qui marche
parfaitement bien et qui me fait des
revenus qui sont extrêmement rapides
soient royal quote je monte en 4 kg un
truc est vraiment cool qui marche très
bien on est quand même sur une machine
coûte relativement cher on est sur un
modèle professionnel donc c'est quand
même pas relativement déconnant je vous
parle du prix un peu plus tard il ya
différentes qu'on fixe est vraiment cool
du temps plus que apple a vraiment joué
le jeu et a gardé le même prix parce
qu'on avait l'année dernière au niveau
des macbook pro 15 pouces
l'autonomie a été aussi augmenté par
rapport à ce qu'on avait l'année
dernière alors pas augmenté par
multiplier c'est pas un truc énorme mais
on va jusqu'à 11 en autonomie en
navigation ça dépend il fois de plus de
vos usages moi clairement il fait
beaucoup de montage comme je tourne tous
les jours je monte tous les jours et
bien l'autonomie va pas durer 11 heures
lorsque je tourne au final cut qui avait
rendu qui se font qu'à tous les plugins
et bien je vais pas le garder aussi
longtemps mais c'est normal ça
correspond à mes usages le mouillé pour
la question de bureautique pour la
question de travail vous êtes vraiment
tranquille autonomistes surtout été un
peu compliqué à quantifier parce que ça
dépend vraiment des usages ça dépend de
ce que vous allez faire l'ol on se
retrouve sur macos catalina qui est
préinstallé qu'il fonctionne chez apple
vous avez une maîtrise de a à z que ce
soit au niveau du hardware du matériel
et au niveau software de point de vue
logiciel voyez je sais déjà fait de
l'anglais du français tout ce mélange en
même temps mais ça c'est vraiment une
des forces de la marque quel que soit
son matériel que ce soit sur les iphone
sur les matches tout ce que vous voulez
il maîtrise la chaîne de a à z dont vous
avez en tout cas absolument optimiser et
c'est en tout cas pour moi un des points
forts de cette machine un des points
très importants sur ce mal bouffe pour
cette année c'est la question du clavier
il y avait eu des problèmes sur les
anciennes versions avec les claviers
papillon apple a revu sa copie vous
propose un magic qui bordent qui est
inspiré du mac pro j'ai l'impression
qu'on est une course qui est un peu plus
longue
apple nous annonce une course de 1 mm je
trouve légèrement plus longue à quelque
chose près mais c'est vraiment un film
par rapport à ce que vous aviez dernière
sur le macbook pro 15 pouces c'est un
mécanisme à 6o je trouve très confort à
l'utilisation vous avez aussi le grand
retour de la touche escape qui est là ça
va être une grosse critique avait
apporté apple effectivement d'avoir une
touche est ce qu'elle est intégrée à la
touchpad
là on la retrouve en physique au plus
grand bonheur pas mal de personnes vous
avez également tôt chelsea qui se
trouvent ici qui a été séparée on voit
plus son côté qui vous servent aussi le
bouton pour dire l'allumé qui marche
bien convenir déverrouiller votre mac
toujours vote du marquis se situe le raf
va pouvoir s'adapter en fonction de vos
différentes applications indé
gros point fort du macbook pro c'est
énorme trackpad qui est vraiment énorme
et lorsque vous avez testé une autre
machine
et bien croyez moi ça ça va vous manquer
parce que vous avez vraiment de la place
pour venir travailler
c'est vraiment hyper confort on n'est
pas obligé de tout le temps devait son
doigt pour récupérer on peut naviguer
d'un bout à l'autre de l'écran très
facilement cours des différentes
applications vous allez utiliser ces a
beaucoup beaucoup de confort clic-droit
clic gauche ça fonctionne c'est cool
d'un point de vue global expérience
clavier trackpad fonctionne très très
bien vous vous retrouvez également votre
petite caméra facetime qui est planqué
juste là là par la lafa et les besoins
ponctuels et la petite caméra facetime
vous avez également du bluetooth 5.0
alors moi dans l'absolu c'est une
machine que j'aime bien on est sur une
évolution de la gamme le fait d'avoir
cet écran 16 pouces ça apporte quelque
chose de plus on aurait pu avoir un
écran 15 pouces et avoir toujours autant
plus de performance la grosse nouveauté
se situe vraiment là premier point c'est
l'écran 16 pouces deuxième point c'est
le clavier qui change pour éviter tous
les problèmes toutes les déconvenues qui
avec le clavier est donc un macbook pro
qui est améliorée mais nous ferons plus
performant mais surtout une direction
qui est intéressante et reprise par
apple apple est toujours à l écoute des
clients disant ok ok des problèmes au
niveau du clavier en corrigeant en
modifie aurait qui fait problème et pas
sur autre chose ok la touche et skate ne
marche pas ok on vous écoute on leur
ajoute donc à une vraie écoute de la
part d'apple au niveau des clubs l'ont
chassé plutôt intéressant macbook pro
mac que j'aime bien vous les états leur
effectivement au niveau des tarifs
apple n'a pas décollé et pour le coup a
vraiment joué le jeu par rapport à un
consommateur
c'est là mon sens la fiche de prix je
vous prends les deux conflits de basse
menées pour retrouver si vous avez sur
le site d'apple intel core i7 à une des
radios joly parce que je connais par
coeur il ya tellement de choses au bout
elles dégradées ou kroos 5300 m 4 gigas
de mémoire gddr5 arts graphiques 16 giga
de ram ddr 4,512 giga en ssd là vous
êtes à 2699 euros alors 2009 99 euros
c'est de l'argent c'est beaucoup
d'argent j'en conviens mais on reste
dans les tarifs d'appel et si vous
regardez effectivement à la concurrence
vous allez pouvoir trouver sur des
configurations équivalente eh bien on se
retrouve dans cette même gamme de prix
donc on est sur un modèle professionnel
si on avait quelque chose de victimes en
un peu moins cher on va aller sur un
macbook air et si vous voulez un modèle
pro avec beaucoup de performances
le macbook pro comme son nom l'indiqué
marche très très bien et alors apprécié
voulait monter au niveau de la confi
intel core i9 à une des radios au 5500m
4 gigas de mémoire
si ce graphique 16 giga de ram ddr 4 1
tera de stockage en ssd vous arrivez à
3199 l'euro on a une différence de 500
euros et ça peut voir un coup de monter
sur un intel core i9 en fonction de vos
usages bien évidemment c'est toujours la
question des usages qui doit être
privilégié pour la question des specs ça
sert à rien d'avoir une machine
extrêmement performant ces dernières
vous n'allez pas l'utiliser souvent les
pales usages et après vous avoir monté
en prix en fonction de la configuration
vous allez souhaité avoir tout de suite
c'est vrai que les prix peuvent
rapidement s'envoler
ça dépend de ce que voulait faire si
vous faites de la vidéo comme moi prenez
au minimum 32 gigas de mémoire ddr4 déjà
six fois c'est de 16 à 32 il faut
rajouter 480 euros
ça monte 64 960 et si je montre ma carte
graphique je passais de 4 giga de
mémoire gddr5 à 8 gigas et bien je vais
inscrire plus 120 euros bon pourquoi pas
ça n'est pas effectivement ce que vous
faites donc ça c'est vraiment à prendre
en compte et aprilia sur la question du
stockage qui là-bas tout de suite monté
là j'avais la config acquerra si je
passe à deux terrasses et plus 484 terra
plus 1200 euros viterra plus 2640 euros
et là ça devient quand même relativement
d'agde
mais ça dépendra plus de vos usages à
défendre ce que vous allez en faire
dites vous bien que lorsque vous allez
acheter une machine comme ça avec la
performance nous est derrière ces deux
sites vous allez garder entre 5 à 10 ans
c'est un usage professionnel
on réfléchit amortissement dans le temps
ça coûte cher ok mais par contre
derrière vous avez de la performance de
renault est ce qu'ils maîtrisaient qui
marche très bien cette machine je trouve
vraiment cool elle marche très bien pour
moi le gros point intéressant c'est le
plus en termes de performances
c'est ce qui permet vraiment d'améliorer
significativement la productivité vous
comment vous trouvez est-ce que vous
utilisez un macbook pro est ce que vous
avez un macbook pro 15 pouces est ce que
vous pourriez aller sur l'agout pro 16
pouces
est ce que vous l'avez déjà et quel
logiciel vous utilisez si c'est le cas
comme moi final cut photoshop est ce que
vous êtes musiciens musiciennes logic
logic pro et est-ce que vous utilisez le
condo macbook pro ipad pro je testerai
dans quelques temps ça a l'air vraiment
très intéressant j'ai vu plein de choses
j'ai hâte de le faire c'est moi tout ça
on va en commentant campagne on retrouve
dès demain pour continuer à parler tech
nous embarque à demain ciao